[Musica]
Un uomo entra in un
caffè Splash Questa è una
barzelletta una brutta barzelletta
riproviamo Un uomo entra in un
tedes CL CL
Grazie Appo anche molto
spontaneo quando si parla di barzellette
Un uomo entra in un caffè Splash è
sempre quella che la prima che mi viene
in mente Sarà perché è una delle più
famose anche delle più brutte Non lo
so però comunque è una belletta
conosciuta da tutti e so che tutti voi
bene o male avete sentito una
barzelletta alcuni Magari hanno anche
provato a raccontarne una altri ma penso
molto meno hanno provato a inventarne
una chi ci ha provato sa che non è
facile passare da un foglio bianco a un
qualcosa di anche solo remotamente
divertente oggi
però Proverò a fare quello che non si
dovrebbe fare mai spiegare le
barzellette provo a raccontarvi perché
le cose sono divertenti anche se come
diceva l'autore di Stuart litle di cui
non ricordo assolutamente il nome
sezionare spiegare le barzellette come
are una rana interessa pochi e come
nella vignetta La rana
muore ma facciamo qualche passo indietro
l'umorismo è sempre esistito nella
storia dell'uomo Probabilmente perché ci
aiuta a comunicare o a superare momenti
difficili in tempi un po' più antichi
c'erano i giullari di corte uomini
stipendiati appositamente per far ridere
re per distrarlo e lasciare che si
rilassi rilass per potersi poi dedicare
alle cose che contavano davvero quelle
più difficili ma i giullari di corte
oggi probabilmente non farebbero più
ridere a noi era una comicità basata su
sputi calci spintoni schiaffi e tante
situazioni molto
grattes l'umorismo Infatti si evolve al
pari di come si evolve la società e si
basa sull'assunto che la situazione di
partenza sia conosciuta dal pubblico ad
esempio nella vignetta che vedete e fa
ridere funziona perché tutti sappiamo
che i dottori scrivono da cani se non
fosse così se non facesse parte
dell'immaginario collettivo Ovviamente
nessuno la capirebbe e non farebbe
ridere tuttavia anche ciò che un tempo
era
divertente perde di senso se non
riusciamo a capire il perché fa ridere
se non riusciamo a immedesimarci nella
situazione
ehm ciò che per esempio per i nostri
nonni e bisnonni poteva far morire dal
ridere poteva fargli scassare dal risate
A noi potrebbe lasciarci invece più
basiti metto video che prente
[Musica]
conoscete conoscevate questa
canzoncina Questa canzone è stata
scritta nel
1899 un bel po' di tempo fa ed era una
parodia della nuovissima parola
utilizzata dai giovani e
lo che lo utilizzavano al posto di Good
morning or Good evening quando si
telefonavano prima non esisteva questa
parola e pertanto veniva parod zzata
oggi però è una delle parole più diffuse
in tutto il mondo in ogni cultura si
conosce e pertanto farci una canzoncina
sopra per quanto sia simpatica e carina
non ci fa ridere ai Temp Invece sì
E oggi ci lascia un po'
così perciò Quand'è che una battuta Non
fa ridere come nel caso della canzoncina
di prima se non mi sento parte del
contesto noi conosciamo la parola è una
parola sdoganata cosa che magari
all'epoca non era E pertanto non capiamo
dove sia la parte
umoristica secondo luogo se associo
l'argomento a emozioni negative questo
può essere può cambiare Mol da persona a
persona in base al proprio
vissuto ad esempio in questa vignetta
molto ingenua dice aiuto la mia casa Ava
A fuoco ho chiamato i pompieri Ma non
arrivano hai provato a chiamare i pomp
oggi
e veramente molto semplice e e ingenua
Tuttavia l'abbiamo pubblicata nel
lontano 2018 e noi programmiamo i post
di settimana in settimana o anche di
mese in mese Quando riusciamo e fatalità
vuole che pubblichiamo questa vignetta
Nella stessa giornata in cui avviene un
incidente cui vengono coinvolti due
Vigili del Fuoco pertanto una vignetta
che poter far ridere in qualunque altro
giorno dell'anno mal mal capitat m viene
Associata a una situazione drammatica e
pertanto non fa più
ridere Terzo punto stesso già doveva
parare la famosa battuta cosa fanno otto
cani in mare e il canotto l'abbiam
l'abbiamo sentito tutti quanti
dall'asilo alle elementari alle medie e
così via e la conosciamo già per cui
anche un bel gioco di parole in realtà
però avendola ascoltata tante volte non
ci fa più
vedere Infatti secondo una ricerca il
nostro cervello cerca di essere sempre
qualche passo avanti rispetto a ciò che
stiamo ascoltando stimando quali
risultati siano possibili Ma quando
scopriamo che ci stanno raccontando una
barzelletta è che tutte le nostre
previsioni in realtà erano sbagliate
Consideriamo che tutto ciò avviene a
livello
inconscio tutta l'energia utilizzata per
queste previsioni di cui noi non ci
accorgiamo deve dissiparsi e per farlo
finisce nel cortice motorio Secondo
alcuni ricercatori
ehm da questo cortice motorio Si si
causano convulsioni le classiche
risate per me fare queste brevi battute
di tre quattro frasi è un po' Come
risolvere dei piccoli problemi di
matematica la mia settimana enigmistica
eh cerco di ridurre all'osso il più
possibile le situazioni per far sì che
poi ne esca una una frase una battuta
divertente che si chiude in tutto in
molto poco
ehm ad esempio farne tante mi ha fatto
capire che cosa fa ridere e che cosa no
E mi ha fatto capire ad esempio che come
in the office lo zoom finale sulla
faccia basita impossibile del
protagonista che ascolta questa freddura
aumenta l'impatto comico della battuta
ma mi ha anche fatto capire alcune
regolette che aiutano poi a creare una
una battuta per cui quando sono lì col
mio foglio di carta col mio Google doc o
con le note del telefono che devo
passare da un foglio bianco a un
qualcosa di divertente uso alcune
strategie che ho notato essere comuni
nella maggior parte delle
battute Allora la risata di solito nasce
da uno spiazzamento e forse la forma più
comune di più comune di battuta e si
crea quando c'è una parte iniziale
facilmente comprensibile dal pubblico e
una seconda parte che rovescia
questa questa situazione iniziale in
questo modo il pubblico viene spiazzato
e si crea la la risata Ad esempio in
questa vignetta dice finora ho aperto
tre buste di compleanno e ho trovato
€200
Adoro fare il
postino adesso faccio quello che dicevo
prima uccido la La rana e vado a
dissezionare la la vignetta nella prima
parte
eh È chiaro a tutti che lui sta aprendo
le buste di compleanno solo nella
seconda dato che vedi che è un postino e
sta rubando i soldi delle buste di
compleanno in quel modo funziona la
battuta nella prima c'è una parte molto
semplice non ti aspetti che ci sia una
situazione così lontana nella seconda
ribalta quello che hai pensato e di
conseguenza scatena la parte umoristica
o ancora Bentornati all'incontro per
guire dalla dipendenza da chirurgia
plastica vedo un sacco di facce nuove
questo non è un buon
inizio anche in questo caso situazione
molto semplice che viene poi
ribaltata il secondo modo e quando si
conosce bene il primo metodo si può
spingere oltre lo spiazzamento
eh rendendo divertente la battuta
Proprio perché diventa non sense ad
esempio Gesù c'è solo del pane del pesce
siamo in troppi non bastano dammeli ci
penso io Ma te li sei mangiati Sì ma non
sei Gesù vero
no anche in questo caso Cioè lui non ha
mai risposto Sì sono Gesù dammeli però
lo dai per assodato perché ci somiglia e
poi non era
lui ancora Ti piace la pizza Certamente
e i funghi Purtroppo no allora non ti
piacerà quello che ti sto per dire mi
hai preso la pizza con i funghi No sono
letto con tua sorella
anche qui la situazione diventa
paradossale il personaggio a sinistra
Ugo cerca di girarci talmente tanto
attorno per dirgli Questa cosa che non
ha più nessun senso o questa che non
commento nemmeno assomiglia proprio a
suo padre suo
padre il terzo
metodo forse quello più comune a quello
che facciamo sono le freddure delle
battute in cui il gioco principale è un
gioco il l'elemento principale è un
gioco di parole esempio signor giudice
c'è una gallina Fuori dal tribunale e
che vuole vorrebbe deporre o
ancora pistola 20% salve salve salve
100% pistola caricata Salve Queste sono
molto semplici da fare
perché basta trovare una parola che ha
due significati tipo pesca il frutto ees
la canna da pesca e creare una
situazione attorno per far funzionare
molto più facilmente la
battuta Tuttavia se non ci viene in
mente né una situazione da capovolgere
né una parola con due significati posso
sempre ricorrere al quarto metodo cioè
il fa ridere perché è vero si prende una
situazione tratta dal vissuto quotidiano
ci si fa ironia sopra in questo modo la
gente ci si immedesima perché penso
l'abbiamo vissuto un po' tutti
Quindi tipo la comunicazione è la cosa
più importante in un rapporto ma che hai
niente
notte penso che in tanti
sappiano ancora il guru che dice Lavora
fino a quando il tuo conto in banca non
sembrerà un numero di telefono fa quindi
ce l'ho
fatta
18 Dipende dalle cifre Qual è la sogni
In verità ne miei sogni non lavoro che
questo forse quando ero piccolo c' tutti
bambini che dicevano Ah io voglio fare
l'astronauta io il calciatore Io niente
quindi ce l'ho
fatta ma non vi fidate delle regole
perché a far ridere Non si insegna ho
letto dozzine di articoli saggi consigli
e tirate intellettuali su come si
costruisce la battuta perfetta ma la
verità è che l'umorismo non è matematica
e pertanto è molto soggettivo da persona
a persona e se la matematica non è
un'opinione l'umorismo Sì ciò che può
far ridere una persona può non far
ridere un'altra persona Perciò vado a
distruggere tutto ciò che vi ho detto
finora e vi dico cosa vi portate a casa
Non lo so un bel mucchio di
niente ora Adesso vorrei chiudere questo
Talk con una frase di Ar Ball
l'inventore dello smiley per chi non
sapesse do an Act of kindness Help One
person smile il tema per questo e la
gentilezza e pertanto vorrei dirvi
quanto per me queste parole significhino
molto ma in realtà ho solo cercato frasi
sulla gentilezza su
Google
[Musica]
grazie